The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK, so.
These are our two topics.
And, Thanksgiving is
coming up, of course.
With convolutions, where are we?
I'm probably starting
a little early.
Oh, I am.
Is that right?
Yeah, OK.
So, with convolutions,
I feel we've
got a whole lot of formulas.
We practiced on some
specific examples,
but we didn't see
the reason for them.
We didn't say the use of them.
And I'm unwilling to
let a whole topic,
important topic
like convolutions,
go on with just formulas.
So I want to talk about
signal processing.
So that's a nice, perfect
application of convolutions.
And you'll see it.
You'll see the point,
and it's something
that you're going
to end up doing.
And it's quite a simple
idea, once you understand
convolutions you've got it.
OK, but then I do want to go on
to the Fourier integral part.
And basically, today I'll
just give the formulas.
So you've got the
Fourier integral formulas
that take from a function
f, defined for all x now.
It's on the whole line,
like some bell-shaped curve
or some exponential decaying.
And then you get its transform,
I could call that c(k),
but a more familiar
notation is f hat of k.
So that will be the Fourier
integral transform, or just
for short, Fourier
transform of f(x),
and it'll involve
all frequencies.
So we are getting away from
the periodic case and integer
frequencies, to the whole
line case with a whole line
of frequencies.
OK, so is that alright?
Finishing, I'll have more to
say about 4.4 convolutions,
but I want to say this much.
OK, let's move to an example.
So here's a typical
block diagram.
In comes the signal.
Vector x, values x_k.
Often, in engineering
and EE, people
tend to write that
x of k, these days.
OK, so, as being easier to type.
And sort of better.
But I'll stay with
the subscript.
So that signal comes in.
And it goes through a filter.
And I'm taking the simplest
filter I can think of,
the one that just
averages the current value
with the previous value.
And we want to see what's
the effect of doing that.
So we want to see, we want
to understand the outputs,
the y_k's, which are
just the current value
and the previous value averaged.
We want to see that
as a convolution,
and see what it's doing.
OK, so that's the-- And
I guess that here, it's
a frequent convention in signal
processing to basically pretend
that the signal is
infinitely long.
That there's no
start and no finish.
Of course, in reality there
has to be a start and a finish.
But if it's a long, you know
if it's a cd or something,
and you're sampling it every--
thousands and thousands
of times.
And the input signal is so
long and you're not really
caring about the very
start and the very end.
It's simpler to just
pretend that you've
got numbers for all k.
OK, then let's see what
kind of a filter this is.
What does it do to the signal?
OK.
Well, one way filters
are-- First of all,
let's see it as a convolution.
So I want to see that this
formula is a convolution,
that the output y, that
output of all the averages y,
is the convolution
of some filter, some,
and I'll give it a proper
name, with the input.
And notice that, again,
there's no circle around here.
We're not doing the
cyclic case, we're just
pretending infinitely long.
So OK, now I just want
to ask you what is the h,
I want to recognize
this as a filter.
So that convolution, let's
remember the notation.
And then we can
match this to that.
So remember the notation
for that would be,
for a convolution
is, I take a sum.
Of all x-- Of h sub
l, x sub k-l, right?
That's what convolution is.
This is our famous, and it would
be in principle the sum over l.
Sum over l's.
So the filter is defined by
these numbers h, these h's,
h_0, h_1, so on.
Those numbers h multiply the
x's, where this familiar rule
to give the k-th output.
OK, let's have no mystery here.
What are the h's if
this is the output?
Well, I want to
match that with that.
So here I see that this takes
x_k, multiplies by a half.
So that tells me
that when l is zero,
I'm getting h_0 times
x_k, so what's h_0?
So what's the h_0?
It's 1/2.
That's what this
formula is saying.
When l is zero,
so l is zero, take
h_0, 1/2, times x_k, ta-da.
Now, what's the other h
that's showing up here?
This is a very,
very short filter.
It's only going to have two
coefficients, h_0 and h what?
One.
And what's the coefficient h_1?
What's the number h_1?
Now you've told me
everything about h
when you tell me that number.
Everybody sees it.
It's also 1/2, right?
Because I'm taking
1/2 of x_(k-1).
So when l is that one, we have
h, the h is 1/2, times x_(k-1).
Do you see that that simple
averaging, running average,
you could call it.
Running average, it's
the most, the first thing
you would think of to-- Why
would you do such a thing?
Why is filtering done?
This filter, this averaging
filter, would smooth the data.
So the data comes
with noise, of course.
And what you'd like, so noise
is high-frequency stuff.
So what you want to do is like
damp those high frequencies
a little bit, because
much of it is not,
it hasn't got information in it.
It's just noise, but you
want to keep the signal.
So it's always this
signal-to-noise ratio.
That's the key -- SNR.
PSNR.
That's the constant expression,
signal-to-noise ratio.
And we're sort of expecting here
that the signal-to-noise ratio
is pretty good.
High.
Mostly signal.
But there's some noise.
This is a very simple,
extremely short, filter.
So this vector h, it's
a proper convolution.
You could say h has
infinitely many components.
But they're all zero,
except for those two.
Right, do you see it?
Another way, just at
the end of last time,
I asked you to think of a matrix
that's doing the same thing.
Why do I bring a matrix in?
Because anytime I
see something linear,
and that's incredibly
linear, right?
I think OK, there's
a matrix doing it.
So these y's, like y_k, y_(k+1),
all the y's are coming out.
The x's are going in, x_k,
x_(k+1), x_(k-1), bunch of x's.
And there's a matrix
doing exactly that.
And what does that matrix have?
Well, it has 1/2
on the diagonal.
So that y_k will
have a 1/2 of x_k,
and what's the other
entry in that row?
I want 1/2 of x_k, and I
want 1/2 of x_(k-1), right?
So I just put 1/2 next to it.
So there is the main
diagonal of the halves,
and there is the
sub-diagonal of the half.
So it's just constant diagonal.
Now, yeah, let me
tell you the word.
When an engineer,
electrical engineer
looks at this, first thing,
or this, any of these.
First letters he uses is
linear time-invariant LTI.
So linear we understand, right?
What does this
time-invariant mean?
Time-invariant means that
you're not changing the filter
as the signal comes through.
You're keeping a
half and a half.
You're keeping the formula.
The formula doesn't
depend on k, the numbers
are just 1/2 and 1/2.
They're the same, so if I shift
the whole signal by a thousand,
the output shifts by
a thousand, right?
If I take the whole
signal and delay it,
delay it by a thousand
time, clock times?
Then the same output will come
a thousand clock times delayed.
So linear time-invariant.
That would be-- I mean,
linear time-invariant
is just talking convolution.
I mean, that's what it comes to
if we're in discrete problems.
It's just that, for some h.
Now, our h deserves like,
the other initials you see.
OK, that was linear
time invariant.
Now, the next
initials you'll see
will be F-I-R.
It's an FIR filter.
So that's finite
impulse response.
What's the impulse
response mean?
It means the h.
The vector h is the
impulse response.
The vector h is what you
get if I put an impulse in,
what comes out?
Just tell me, what happens here.
Suppose an impulse,
by an impulse
I mean I stick a one in one
position and all zeroes.
Our usual delta.
Our impulse, our
spike, is just, suppose
the x's have a one
here, otherwise
all zero, what comes out?
Well, suppose there's
just x_0 is one.
What is y?
Suppose the only
input is boom, you
know a bell sounds at time zero.
What comes out from the filter?
Well, y_0 will be what?
If the input has
just a single x,
and it's one, at that
time zero, so x_0 is one.
Then y_0 will be?
1/2, and what will be y_1?
Also 1/2, right?
Because y_1 will
take x_1, that's
already dropped back to zero.
Plus x_0, that's the bell.
It'll be 1/2.
In other words,
the output is this.
No big deal.
The impulse responses
is exactly h.
So you can say they've created
a long word for a small idea,
true.
And the idea, the word finite
is the important number.
Finite, meaning that
it's finite length,
I only have a finite number of
h's, and in this case two h's.
So that's-- Part of every
subject is just learning
the language.
So LTI, it means you've
got a convolution.
FIR means that the
convolution has finite length.
OK, now for the question.
What is this filter
doing to the signal?
It's certainly averaging.
That's clear.
But we want to be more precise.
Well, let me take some examples.
Suppose the input is all ones.
All x_k are one.
So a constant input.
Natural thing to test.
That's the constant input,
that's zero frequency.
Zero frequency.
What's the output?
From all ones going in.
Wow, sorry to ask you
such a trivial question.
You came in for
some good math here,
and I'm just taking 1/2 and 1/2.
So the output is all
y's equal, right?
So, to me, that's
telling, just to introduce
an appropriate word, low
frequencies; in fact,
bottom frequency,
zero frequency,
is passed straight through.
That's a lowpass filter.
That's telling me I
have a lowpass filter.
So that's an expression.
That's so simple that you
might as well know those words.
Lowpass means that the
lowest frequencies pass
through virtually unchanged.
In this case, the very zero
frequency, the DC term,
the constant term, passes
through completely unchanged.
Now, what about another
input all-- Well,
now I want high frequencies.
Top frequencies.
What's the most-- The
highest oscillation I can get
would be x equal, say, it starts
one, minus one, one, minus one,
so on.
Both directions.
Oscillating as fast as possible.
I couldn't get a faster
frequency of oscillation
in a discrete signal
than up, down, up, down.
What's the output for that?
So that's really oscillation.
That's the fastest oscillation.
What would be the
output from my averaging
filter for this input?
Zero.
At every step, I'm averaging
this with the guy before
and they add to zero.
I'm averaging this with the
guy before, this with the guy--
Output is, y equals all zeroes.
OK, so that confirms in my mind
that I have a lowpass filter.
The high frequencies
are getting wiped out.
OK, so that's two examples.
Now, what about
frequencies in between?
Because ultimately
we want to see
what's happening to
frequencies in between.
OK, so what's an
in-between frequency?
So in between, x_k could
be e^(ikn), let's say.
e^(ik*omega).
Where this omega is somewhere
between minus pi and pi.
OK, why do I say
minus pi and pi?
If the frequency-- So
that's the frequency.
If omega is zero,
what's my signal?
All ones, right?
If omega is zero,
everything is my all ones.
This is this case.
So I now have a letter
for it, omega=0.
What's this top frequency?
One, minus one, one,
minus one, what omega
will give me alternating signs?
Omega equal?
Pi, right?
Omega=pi.
Because if this is pi, I have
e^(i*pi), which is minus one.
So when omega=pi, my inputs are
e^(i*omega), to the k-th power.
But this is minus one.
e^(i*pi), to the k-th power,
and that's minus one.
So that's the top frequency.
And also the bottom
frequency is pi.
And the zero frequency
is the all ones.
And this is what happens-- Ah.
Now comes the point.
What's the output if
this is the input?
What's the output when
We can easily figure that out.
We can take that average.
OK, so let me do that input.
Input x_k is e^(ik*omega).
And now what's the output?
y_k is the average of that.
And the one before.
Divided by two, right?
OK, now you're certainly
going to factor out,
anybody who sees this is going
to factor out e^(ik*omega),
right?
I mean that's
sitting there, that's
the whole point of
these exponentials
is they factor out
of all linear stuff.
So if I factor that out, I get
a very, very important thing.
I get, well, it's
over two, I get a one.
And I get, what's this
term? e^(ik*omega) is here.
So I only want e^(-i*omega).
OK, that is called the
frequency response.
So that's telling
me the response
of-- what the filter
does to frequency omega.
It multiplies the signal.
If I have a signal that's
purely with frequency omega,
that signal is getting
multiplied by that response
factor.
1+e^(i*omega).
When omega is zero,
what is this quantity?
So let me call this
cap H of omega.
What is this factor,
if omega is zero?
Then H at omega=0 is?
One.
That's telling me again
that at zero frequency
the output is the
same as the input.
Multiplied by one.
And at omega equal to pi, what
is this frequency response?
Zero, right.
At omega=pi, this is
minus one so I get zero.
And it's telling me again
that this is the response.
And now it's also telling me
what the response factor is
for the frequencies in between.
And everybody would draw a
graph of the darn thing, right?
So this was simple, let
me do its graph over here.
So I'm going to graph H(omega).
Well, I've a little problem.
H(omega)'s a complex number.
I'll graph the
magnitude response.
So here I'm going to do a
graph from minus pi to pi.
This is the picture.
This is the picture
people look at.
This is the picture of
what the filter is doing.
All the information about
the filter is in here.
All the information is in there.
So if I graph that, I know
what the filter's doing.
So you said at omega=0,
I get a value of one.
At omega=pi, I get
a value of zero.
At omega equal minus pi,
I get a value of zero.
And I think if you
figure out the magnitude,
it's just a cosine.
It's just an arc of a cosine.
OK, for that really,
really simple filter.
So any engineer, any
signal processing person,
looks at this graph
of H(omega) and says
that is a very fuzzy filter.
A good, an ideal filter,
an ideal lowpass filter,
would do something like this.
An ideal filter would stay
at one up to some frequency,
say pi/2.
And drop instantly to zero.
There is a really good filter.
I mean, people would pay
money for that filter.
Because what happens
when you send a signal
through that ideal filter?
It completely wipes out
the top frequencies.
Let's say, up after pi/2.
And it completely saves
the in-between ones.
So that's really a sharp filter.
Actually, what people
would like to do
would be to have that
filter available.
And then also to have a
perfect, ideal highpass filter.
What would be an
ideal highpass filter?
Yeah, let's talk about
highpass filters just a moment.
Because this is, you're seeing
the reality of what people do,
and how they-- and that little
easy bit of math they do.
Do you want to suggest
a highpass filter,
let me come back to this?
And just change it a little?
So I plan to do not-- I'm now
going to do a different filter.
That's going to be
a highpass filter.
And what do I mean by that?
A highpass filter
will kill the x_k=1.
I now want the output from--
This is now going to be,
I'm going to change.
Can I just erase,
change a lot of things?
I'm now going to produce
a highpass filter.
Sorry, pi.
And what's the difference?
When all x's are one, the
output is going to be?
Zero.
And when I have the
highest frequency,
the output is going to be?
The input.
And what am I-- And
then in between, I'll
do something in between.
OK, what do you think
would be a highpass filter,
like the simplest highpass
filter we can think of?
Anybody think of it?
You're only getting, like, 15
seconds to think in this class.
That's a small
drawback, 15 seconds.
But, the highpass filter
that I think of first
is, take the difference.
Take the difference.
Put minus a halfs
on the sub-diagonal.
This is the same, this
is also a convolution,
but now what? h_0
is still a half.
But now h_1 is?
Minus 1/2.
We're still convolving.
We're still
convolving, it's still
linear time-invariant, that
just means it's a convolution.
It's still a finite
impulse response.
But the response, the impulse
response is now 1/2 minus 1/2.
So what happens if I,
in my picture over here,
if I send in any pure frequency,
I'm now doing minus 1/2 here.
So I'll just keep the plus.
But I'll also add in the minus.
So now I'm looking at one
minus e^(-i*omega) over two.
And again, let's plot a
few points for that guy.
So what, at x, at
omega-- So this
is omega in this direction.
And this is h in this direction.
So at omega=0, what's
my highpass guy?
When I send in a zero frequency,
constant, I get what output?
Zeroes, because now-- I'll
call it a differencing filter.
So I'll just, instead of
averaging I'm differencing.
OK, so now for this
one, maybe I'll
put an x to indicate
I'm now doing,
I'll do x's for the high pass.
So this now, the high pass
guy, kills the low frequency
and preserves the
high frequency.
And you won't be
surprised to find
it's some cosine or
something that, well yeah,
it's got-- Sorry, that's
not much of a cosine.
It's the mirror image
of the lowpass guy.
And maybe the sum
of squares adds
to one or two or something.
One, probably.
The sum of squares
probably adds to one.
And they're kind of
complementary filters.
But they're very poor.
Very crude, I mean that's so
far from the ideal filter.
So how would we create a
closer to ideal filter?
Well, we need more h's.
With two h's, we're
doing the best we can,
with just h_0 and h_1.
With a longer filter,
for which we're
going to have to pay
a little more to use,
but we'll get a lot more.
We'll get something,
we could get
a filter that stays pretty close
to this, drops pretty fast.
There's a whole world.
Bell Labs had a little
team of filter experts.
Creating, and now
MATLAB will create it
for you, the coefficients
h, that would give you
a response, a frequency
response, that'll
stay up toward, up close
to one as long as possible.
And drop as fast as possible,
and bounce around there.
So next week, if I come
back to that topic,
I can say a little more about
these really good filters.
What was I trying to do today?
Trying to see how
convolution is used.
And this is a use
you will really make.
So now I just have, I
think, about two more things
to say about this example.
Let's see, what are they?
Well, first, so
all the information
is in this H(omega).
Oh, yeah.
This simple example gives us a
way to visualize convolution.
And I think we need that.
Right?
Because up to now, convolution
has been a formula.
Right?
It's been this formula.
That's the formula
for convolution,
and how do I visualize that?
Just think of, may I
try to visualize that?
Here I have, this
is the time line.
The different k's. k equals
zero, one, two, minus one.
And I have x_(-1),
x_0, x_1, x_2, x_3.
So that would be a little
bouncy up and down.
And the averaging filter, let
me go back to the averaging one.
The averaging filter would
smooth out the bumps.
Because it would take the, it
would, like, average neighbors.
And that's a smoothing process.
As we see here, it's a process
that kills high frequencies.
Now, what is this visualization
I want you to think of?
I want you to just think
of, like, a moving window.
So here is the input.
Now, I move a window along.
And that window, so let's
say here's the window,
I should have another.
So that's the window.
When the window is there, it
takes the average of those two.
That gives me the new output.
Now, think of the window
as moving along here,
taking the average of these.
Move the window along,
take the average of these.
Move the window along.
Do you see the sort of, this
is what a convolution is doing.
This is a picture of my
formula, sum of h_k*x_(l-k).
So the window is the h's,
is the width of the h's,
and as that window moves along.
I mean, you could
write, you could create,
design a little circuit
that would do exactly this.
That would do the convolution.
You just have to put
together some multipliers,
because you have these
h's, these, like, halves.
And you have to put in an
adder, that'll add the pieces.
And those are the essential
little electronic pieces
of an actual filter.
Then you just move it along.
So it needs a delay.
That's about the
content of a filter.
Is multipliers that will
multiply by the h's, so in come
the x, multiply by the
h's, do the addition,
and do a shift to get
onto the next one.
You see how a filter works?
I think that image
of convolution
is a little bit vague, maybe?
This window moving along?
But it's quite meaningful.
And then the final thing I'll
say about filters is this.
That, what's the connection
between H(omega) and h(k)?
Or h sub k, let me
call it h sub k.
What's the connection
between the numbers
in impulse response, just, which
were the h's, and the function,
which is the frequency response,
which tells me what happens
to a particular frequency?
Each frequency, e
to the-- You notice
how the frequency
that went in is
the frequency that comes out.
It's just amplified
or diminished
by this H(omega) factor.
So you see the h's are the
coefficients here of H(omega).
In other words,
H(omega) is the sum
of the h_k's, e to the--
e to the minus ik--
Here's the beautiful formula.
That's obvious, right?
Here you're seeing the
formula in the simplest case,
with just an h_0 and an h_1.
But of course, it would have
worked if I had several h's.
So this H(omega), this
factor that comes out,
is just this guy.
Now, if I look at
that, what am I saying?
I've seen things that
connect a function of omega
with a number of
filter coefficients.
I saw that in Section
4.1, in Fourier series.
This is the Fourier
series for that function.
Right?
You might say, OK,
why that minus?
I say, it's there because the
electrical engineers put it
there.
They liked it.
And the rest of the world
has to live with it.
So, you notice I
don't concede on i.
I refuse to write j.
But they all would.
I speak about they, but
probably some you would write j.
So I'm hoping it's OK if I
write i. i is for imaginary.
I don't see how you could say
the word imaginary starting
with a j.
And what was the
matter with i, anyway?
Current.
Well, current used to be i.
I mean who, is it still?
Well, let's just accept it.
OK, they can call the current
i, and the square root
of minus one j,
but not in 18.085.
So OK, here we are.
So my point is just that
we have a Fourier series.
Here we a 2pi periodic function.
Here we have its
Fourier coefficients.
The only difference is that we
started with the coefficients.
And created the function.
But otherwise, we're back to
Section 4.1, Fourier series.
But that fact that we
started with the coefficients
and built the
function, sometimes you
could say, OK that
sounds a little
different from the
regular Fourier series,
where you go the other way.
So people give it the
name discrete-time
Fourier transform.
You might see those
letters sometime.
The discrete-time
Fourier transform
goes from the coefficients
to the function.
Where the standard Fourier
series starts with a function,
goes to the coefficients.
But really, it doesn't matter.
The point is, yeah.
So you could say, maybe we
have now a fourth transform.
Like the first transform
was Fourier series.
The second one was the discrete.
The third one is
the Fourier integral
that's coming in one minute.
And the fourth is this one.
But hey, it's just
the coefficients
and the function have
switched places, in the,
which one is the start and
which one is at the end.
OK, let me pause a
minute because that's
everything I wanted to
say about simple filters.
And you can see that this
is a very simple filter,
and could be improved.
Better numbers
would give, I mean
what would be better numbers?
I suppose that 1/4, 1/2, 1/4
would probably be better.
If I took those
numbers, I'm pretty
sure that this thing would be
closer to ideal by quite a bit.
If I plotted-- So what do I
mean by, those are the h's.
So I would take 1/4 plus
1/2 e^(-i*omega) plus 1/4
e^(-2i*omega).
This would be my
better H(omega).
This would be my frequency
response to a better averaging
filter, sort of this is like
averaged averaged, right?
If I do a half an average and
then I do the average again.
In other words, if I just
send these signals y_k
through that same averaging
filter, so average
again to get a z_k, I think
probably the coefficients
would be 1/4, 1/2,
1/4, and it would
be, I've taken out more noise.
Right?
Each time I did that averaging,
I damp the high frequencies,
so if I do it twice
I get more damping.
But I lose signal, of course.
I mean, presumably there's
some information in the signal
in these frequencies.
And I'm reducing it.
And if I average twice
I'm reducing it further.
So a better one would be
to get a sharp cutoff.
OK, that's filters.
I guess what I hope is that we
have the idea of a convolution,
and now we see what
we can use it for.
Right?
And there are many others.
So we'll have another.
We'll come back to convolutions
and de-convolution.
Because if you
have a CT scanner,
that doing a little convolution.
I mean, you're the input,
right, to the CT scanner?
You march in,
hoping for the best.
OK, CT scanner convolves you
with their little filter.
And then it does
a deconvolution,
to an approximate deconvolution,
to have a better image of you.
OK, let's leave that.
Can I change direction
and just write down
the formulas for the
Fourier integral transform?
And do one example?
OK.
I don't know what you
think about a lecture that
stops and starts a new topic.
Is it, maybe it's
tough on the listener?
Or maybe it's a break.
I don't know.
Let's look at it positively.
Alright, break.
Alright.
So let me remember the
Fourier series formulas.
So I'm just going
to break, and now we
go to the integral transform.
OK, so let me remember the
formula for the coefficients,
which was 1/(2pi), the integral
of f(x)e^(-ikx)dx, right?
And then when we added it
up to get f(x) back again,
we added up a sum of the
c_k's e^(ikx)'s, right?
That's 4.1.
We know those formulas.
And we notice again.
Complex conjugate.
One direction is the
conjugate compared
to the other direction.
Now, all I plan to do is
write down the formula.
And remember, I'm going
to use f hat of k,
instead of the coefficients.
Because it's a function of k,
all k's and not just integers
are allowed.
And then I'm going
to recover f(x).
OK, now this integral
went from minus pi
to pi, because
that was periodic.
But now all the integrals are
going to go from minus infinity
to infinity.
We've got every k, every x.
So we take, what do
you expect here? f(x)?
e^(-ikx)?
dx?
Yes.
Fine.
Same thing, f(x) is there, but
now any k is allowed so I have
a function of all k's.
And now I want to recover f(x).
So what do I do?
You can guess.
I've got an integral now.
Not a sum.
Because a sum was when I
had only integer numbers.
Now, I've got f hat
of k, and would you
like to tell me what the
magic factor is, there
in the integral formula?
It's just what you hope.
It's the e^(ik*omega).
d what?
Now this is where it's
easy to make a mistake. d,
I'm integrating here.
I'm putting the whole,
reconstructing the function.
I'm putting back the
harmonics with the amount,
f hat of k tells me how
much e^(ik*omega) there is
in the function.
I put them all together,
so I integrate dk.
I'm integrating over
the frequencies.
This was the sum over k.
From minus infinity to infinity.
Now this is an integral, because
we've got, it's all filled in.
And it remains to
deal with this 2pi.
And I see in the book
that the 2pi went there.
I don't know why.
Anyway, there it is.
So let's follow that convention.
Put the 2pi here.
So there's the formula.
The pair of formulas,
the twin formulas.
The transform, from f to
f hat, and the inverse
transform, from f hat back to f.
And it's just like the one
you've seen for Fourier series.
Well, I think the only
good way to remember
those is to put in a function
and find its transform.
So my final thing for
today would be take
a particular function, f(x).
Here, let me take
ever f(x) to be,
here's one. f to be zero
here, and then a jump to one.
And then an exponential decay.
So e^(-ax).
OK, so that's the input.
It's not odd, it's not even.
So I expect sort of a complex f
hat of k, which I can compute.
So f hat of k is what?
Now, let's just figure
out f hat of k and look
at the decay rate and
all the other good stuff.
So what do I do?
I'm just doing this integral.
For practice.
OK, so f is zero
in the first half.
So I really only integrate
zero to infinity.
And in that region it's e^(-ax),
and I multiply by e^(-ikx),
and I integrate dx,
and what do I get?
I'll get, this is an
integral we can do,
and it's easy because
this is e^(-(a+ik)x).
You're always going to
see it that way, right?
That we're integrating.
And then the integral
of an exponential
is the exponential divided by
the factor that will come down
when we take the derivative.
So I think we just
have this, right?
Don't you think?
To integrate that
exponential, we just
get the exponential divided
by its little factor.
And now we have to
stick in the limits.
And what do I get at the limits?
This is like, a fun part of
Fourier integral formulas.
What do I get at the upper
limit, x equal infinity?
If x is very large,
what does this thing do?
Goes to zero.
It's gone.
The e^(ikx) is oscillating
around, it's of size one.
But the e^(-ax), so I needed
a to be positive here.
That picture had to be
the right one. a positive.
Then at infinity, I get zero.
So now I just plug
in this lower limit,
that comes with a minus sign.
So what do I get?
The minus sign will
make this a+ik,
and what does it
thing equal at x=0?
One. e^0 is one.
So there is the
Fourier transform.
Of my one-sided exponential.
Now, just a quick look at that
and then I'll do some more,
this example's Example
one in Section 4.5,
and we'll do more examples.
But let's just look at that one.
I see a jump in the function.
What do I expect in the
decay rate of the transform?
So a jump in the function, I
expect a decay rate of 1/k.
Decay rate, right?
Just as for Fourier
coefficients, so
for the integral transform.
So a decay rate in f hat.
And it's here.
1/k in the denominator.
Yeah.
So that's a a good example.
You might say, wait a minute,
OK that's fine but what
about the second one?
Could I put in 1/(a+ik)
and get back the pulse?
The exponential pulse?
The answer is yes,
but maybe I don't
know how to do that integral.
So I'm sort of fortunate
that these formulas
are proved for any function
including this function.
So this example
shows the decay rate.
The possibility sometimes
of doing one integral
but maybe the other integral
going the other direction
is not so easy.
And that's normal.
So that's, like, Fourier
transforms and inverse
transforms, we don't expect to
be able to do them all by hand.
I mean, I'll just say
that actually, anybody
who studies complex
variables and residues,
I don't know if you
know any of this,
heard these words about--
There are ways to integrate.
I could put 1/(a+ik) in here.
And, actually, and
do this integral
for minus infinity to infinity.
By stuff that's in Chapter 5.
Can I just point ahead without
any plan to discuss it.
That some integrals can
be done by x+iy tricks,
by using complex numbers.
But I won't do more.
OK, thanks.
So that's the formulas.
And that's one example.
Wednesday there will be more
examples and then no review
session Wednesday evening.